━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
内藤忍の資産デザイン研究所メール＜第六百九十五号2026年7月31日（金）発行＞
資産デザイン研究所メールは、資産運用に役立つ情報を個人投資家の皆様に提供するウィークリー・メールマガジンです。
金融資産だけではなく、不動産をはじめとする実物資産への投資まで、幅広い投資対象を組み合わせる「ハイブリッド投資」の具体的方法を可能な限り客観的な視点でご紹介いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
内藤忍公式ブログ
内藤忍、株式会社資産デザイン研究所は、資産配分などの投資アドバイスは行いますが、金融商品の勧誘・推奨などの投資助言業務は一切行っておりません。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ　〜　こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・勉強会のお知らせ
3　読者の質問コーナー
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
5　資産運用日記
6　内藤忍のつぶやき
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍の公式ブログ Shinoby`s World コラムタイトル一覧＞
毎日更新している公式ブログの、前回メールマガジン配信以降のコラムです。
こちらから全文をお読みいただけます
7月25日 都心マンションをあきらめて郊外戸建を買ってはいけない
7月26日 晴海フラッグの売り物件は「タワー棟ばかり」の理由
7月27日 FIREして海外移住した人が帰国して働き始める理由
7月28日 エーアイで英会話スクールはなくなっても、筋トレジムはなくならない
7月29日 サイゼリヤは値上げと同時に「スペシャルワイン復活」を
7月30日 プルデンシャル生命の問題は「完全歩合」ではない
7月31日 「ファンドラップの9割がプラス」は記事ではなく広告
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍のメディア出演・出版情報＞
【毎月更新】マネックス証券の投資情報サイト「マネクリ」
最新コラムタイトルは
「「1ドル＝200円」時代も覚悟。
資産配分を見直し、事前準備を」
連載一覧はこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ〜こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
今回の為替介入の「賞味期限」は？
きのうのニューヨークしじょうにおいてドル円相場は、それまでの1ドル＝163円台から一気に円高となり一時157円台後半に突入しました。
日本政府による食料品のしょうひ税を2年間減税する方針が発表される前で、日銀の金融政策決定会合の政策金利据え置きとなれば一段の円安の可能性がありました。
それを恐れた政府・日銀による円買い・ドル売りの実弾によるサプライズ介入を行ったと考えるのが妥当です。
再度の介入警戒感もありしばらくは上値を追う動きは当面限定されるはずです。
しかし、為替の長期的な方向性を決めるのはファンダメンタルズであり、長期的な為替見通しについては、私は変わらないと考えます。
アメリカの急激な景気後退による利上げ観測の後退、日銀による積極的な引き締め方針の明示など、日米の金利差が根本的に縮小する動きがなければ長期的には再び円安が進むのではないでしょうか。
アメリカとの金利差は依然として大きく、高金利の外貨を買って低金利の円を売るインセンティブは変わりません。
またデジタル赤字や海外投資に伴う実需の円売り需要も継続しているため、介入は押し目買いを入れるチャンスと考える市場参加者も少なくありません。
高市政権の減税と財政支出拡大の経済政策も円安要因であり、こちらも変わる兆しはありません。
この原稿を書いている7月31日14時時点では、既に1ドル160円台後半までドルが買い戻されています。
今回の為替介入の「賞味期限」は果たしていつまででしょうか？
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・イベントのご案内
現在募集中のセミナー・イベントはございません
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
3　読者の質問コーナー
読者からのご質問に、内藤忍がズバリ回答いたします！
Ｑ：内藤さんはワンルームマンションを積立で購入したと聞きましたが具体的にはどういう方法ですか？
Ａ：ご質問ありがとうございます。
私がさいしょに購入した東京都港区のワンルームマンションは約1800万円の販売価格でしたが、自己資金200万円で1600万円の15年金利1.7％の投資ローンの借り入れを行いました。
借り入れ期間が15年と短いので、毎月の元利均等返済金額は101,760円となりました。
いっぽうで、購入時の管理費や修繕積立金を差し引き後のネット家賃は87,000円です。
毎月のキャッシュフローは差し引きでマイナス15,000円ほどになります。
これは頭金200万円で毎月15,000円の積み立てを15年続けるとワンルームマンションがローンなしで手に入ることを意味します。
敢えてキャッシュフローをマイナスにすることによって、あたかも投資信託の積み立てと同じような毎月積み立てによる資産形成につなげることができました。
こちらのローンはあと3年ほどで返済が終了します。
返済が終われば毎月のネット家賃がインカム収入として手に入るようになります。
ニーサでインデックスファンドの積み立てを行うのも悪くないですが、このように「お金を借りる力」を使った積立投資ならさらに有利な資産運用が可能です。
この方法は金利差があれば、これからでも活用することは可能です。
次回の不動産投資セミナーは9月14日に予定しておりらいしゅうから募集開始予定です。
興味のある方はらいしゅうのメルマガからお申込みください。
このコーナーでは読者の方からのご質問に、資産デザイン研究所だいひょう取締役の内藤忍がメールマガジン上で回答いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
オリジナルカレーが楽しい北参道のワインバー
2024年に開店してから3年目に入った北参道のワインバーに久しぶりに出かけました。
こちらのお店はワインバーなのに、お料理のウリがカレーという変わったお店です。
といっても気を衒ったワインバーではありません。
オーナーの山本さんは虎ノ門にある会員制の高級ワインバーの元支配人で、ケンゾーなどの有名ワイン店にいたこともあるソムリエ。
ワインの目利きはピカイチです。
一本10万円を超えるシャンパーニュやブルゴーニュの高級ワインから数千円の安ウマワインまで、予算と好みに合わせて最高のワインをセレクトしてくれます。
この日は4人で出かけてボトルワインをおまかせで注文しましたが、とても美味しくあっという間にボトルは空に。
追加でさらに赤ワインのボトルを注文しました。
お料理は定番のウフマヨとオリジナルのカレーを注文。
カレーは4種類から選べます。
スパイシーで美味しいのに、ワインの香りを邪魔しない絶妙な仕上がりです。
ボトルワインだけではなくグラスワインも豊富にあってカウンターで1人でワイン1杯でも利用できます。
テーブル席でワインと食事をゆっくり味わうこともでき、居心地よくおいしいお店です。
気に入ったワインはお店にあるショップで買って帰ることもできます。
美味しいワインをカジュアルに楽しく飲んでみたい方は一度出かけてみてください。
小さなお店なので行く前に一本電話してからの方が良いでしょう。
Mine
東京都渋谷区千駄ヶ谷4-10-5
[EN]Asway Sendagaya B1F[/EN]
03-4400-0156
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。